The problem is the pronunciation
where it becomes quite confusing.
How do you pronounce the word?
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here, and
today I'm gonna do a video about
English, about English spelling,
spelling and pronunciation.
Remember, if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe.
Click on the bell for notifications,
and if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
I do appreciate it.
Okay, so most of my videos here Are
about learning other languages because
I'm in the position of an English
speaker learning other languages.
So I give advice to people who
are learning other languages.
Although I am aware that many of
my, uh, subscribers and viewers are
people who are learning English,
and they find it interesting to
listen to what I have to say because
it helps them with their English.
So today I'm gonna talk a
bit about English spelling
and English pronunciation.
So I gave it some thought.
Well, first of all, I created a text.
A text where I sort of combined
all of the inconsistencies of
English spelling in, in a bit...
not all, a number, a few of the
inconsistencies in English spelling
and put them into a lesson at LingQ.
And I'm gonna show you how I would
use that lesson to tag some of these
words in order to focus in on how very
often the same vow or the same word
is pronounced in, or the same letter,
rather, is pronounced in different
ways in English and how there seems
to be an absence of any clear pattern.
I mean, there are some rules,
but it's a bit confusing.
But first, so I gave some thought to
this whole issue of pronunciation.
When I look at languages that I
have learned, okay, I've learned
Chinese, there's a bit of a hint
as to the pronunciation, but you
essentially have to learn each
character as an individual character.
You have to learn how it's pronounced.
You have to learn the tone of
that character, although you
acquire a lot of that naturally.
It's very difficult.
You can't necessarily deduce
from the character how that is
pronounced, what tone it is.
It's not obvious.
You actually have to know the word.
And then I go to, say Greek and um,
Persian, arabic, where there is also
inconsistency between the writing
system and how things are pronounced.
I also found that in many cases I had to
know the word before I could confidently
pronounce it in a number of languages.
Russian, English another example,
you don't know where the emphasis or
how the word, the intonation of the
word, if you don't know the word.
There are other languages like Polish
or Spanish, which are very consistent.
Uh, the spelling, the intonation
matches up to the spelling, the,
you know what the intonation.
Uh, there are, you know,
diacritics to help you.
So some languages are easier that way.
English is not that easy.
So in a way, my basic advice is
to disconnect the writing, the
spelling from the pronunciation.
So if we're only dealing with the
issue of spelling, like you're only
writing, you're not worried about
how words are pronounced, still the
sound of the word, the pronunciation.
Pronunciation comes into it, into
play because you hear the word in
your brain and you're not quite
sure how it's spelled because of the
inconsistency of English spelling.
If there were no sound there, you would
just take each word as a separate word,
like a Chinese character and you would
just know the word believe, meaning
to believe, uh, is IE, I before E.
Whereas receive is EI.
You would just learn that as the word.
You wouldn't be fooled by the fact
that it's the same sound, uh, that
the word need, and in other words
to need do is K N E A D, whereas
to need something is N E E D.
It's confusing, but if you
separated out the sound, you
didn't worry about the sound.
You just remembered that word as a word.
That's how you spell it.
The spelling on its own I think
would be an easier problem.
The problem is the pronunciation
where it becomes quite confusing.
How do you pronounce the word?
And in the end, and I've seen
so many people because the way
the value of letters in our own
language, are so, so hardwired.
There's this tremendous tendency to
pronounce words in English based on how
they would be pronounced if they were
Spanish words, or, you know, Polish words.
So I've often mentioned that my father
who lived in Canada for, you know,
30 uh, years, uh, he continued to say
Nova Scotia instead of Nova Scotia.
He would say "vord" instead of word, even
though he had a phenomenal vocabulary in
English, was completely fluent in English.
But the, the value of those letters
in his original Czech language
was such that he couldn't let go.
Uh, I had, we had a Spanish person
working with us and she kept on saying
"sward" and I'd say no, no, it's sword.
Oh yeah, okay "sword".
Like people can't let go of the value of
those letters in their native language.
So, and I think one
has to kind of divorce.
Don't worry about the letters
because you're going to wanna
pronounce them the way they are
pronounced in your native language.
You have to totally rely on what you hear.
So let me just read this text that I wrote
and which I put in as a lesson in LingQ,
and I'll show you how in that lesson I
go in and I tag words that might give
me trouble for pronunciation so that I
can then review them, uh, in a group.
In, in the vocab section.
But first I'll read you this lesson
for those of you who are learning
English, and you'll see that I start
with A's and I work my way through E.
Oh, it's in fact, I may
not read the whole thing.
You can do the lesson, but I
say beware of English spelling.
I want to warn.
Warn, okay?
I want to warn all of you about
variations in pronunciation.
After all, you see how the A is
pronounced so differently, after all,
maybe if you are aware of these changes,
you may not make so many mistakes.
The hard part is that I can warn you,
scare you, prepare you, and what happens.
You see how the A is pronounced
differently each time.
I won't read through the whole thing.
You can go and find it if you're
interested, but I mean, even like
the letter E, we have a letter,
letter, letter E, Those are all E's.
Then you have, you know, uh, heard,
there's an E, but then you can get the
"ur" sound with bird or word or squirrel.
Um, you know, or, uh, you know, E and...
E And A together can be pronounced
like here, but also like bread
or head, uh, and so on, like,
so, so you'll see this lesson.
I've recorded it, I've put it
into, uh, our library at LingQ.
Uh, just to illustrate how inconsistent,
uh, you know, very famous, of course,
everyone always refers to the whole OU
situation where, you know, you have,
um, so I say here, Uh, you wouldn't
be able to get out OU to travel
about without going through the door.
Although I've heard of people going
through the window that could be
tougher or even rougher, blah blah blah.
And then look out the window.
You see a man plowing with his plow.
Plough is the same as
rough, same spelling.
Sewing the field while his
wife is at home sewing.
So he's sewing the field OW his
wife is sewing, SEW, his shirt
at home, and so on and so on.
Okay, so I will show you how,
how I would use this lesson to
work on my English spelling.
The lesson is an attempt to
show how certain letters can be
pronounced in very different ways.
And it's very difficult sometimes
to tell how they are pronounced.
So I start with a little, with a letter A.
So it says, Beware of English spelling.
I want to, I want to warn you
about variations in pronunciation.
So we see here that in this first
paragraph, I have a lot of words with
the letter A, all pronounced differently.
So I might decide that I
wanna save the word warn.
Uh, so I might even know what the
meaning is, but I want to be able to...
so I save it and then I
decide that I want to tag it.
So I'll tag it and I'll create,
call it, let's see, pronunciation.
So that now all of the words, because
it's not just a letter A, I'm gonna
go through this lesson and you'll see.
Uh, do the same for other letters.
So variation, maybe I
feel Okay, A in variation.
I don't have trouble pronouncing,
so I won't go for that.
But again, aware, you
know, here's another one.
Uh, so I'll save it and I'll give
it a tag and I'll call it again...
and as I start, you know, uh, typing
in the word pronunciation is there,
so I save that as the tag for that.
All right, so changes, you know, A
is pronounced change is mistakes.
I'm not so concerned about that.
Scare, warn, aware, scare, maybe I
also want to give that a tag so I, you
know, save it and then I give it a tag.
And again, I go pronunciation.
Okay.
And I save.
So, And patterns probably,
I'm not so worried about.
Beware, careful, patterns.
Okay, now then we go to E here.
So believe IE some
people might be confused.
So I would go in there and then I
would tag it and I would again go pr...
and that gives me
pronunciation and uh, so that.
And of course, letter,
believe, letter, me.
Um, and so letter can
be, it can be letter.
Uh, um, so I say seeing is believing.
I think by this time, believe probably
I'm not gonna save that, but heard
has an E in it and is pronounced "er".
So, I might say that, and then
I go in there and I say, Let's
tag it for pronunciation.
And, uh, I tag it that way.
And you can go through the whole lesson.
Uh, heard, bird, heard,
I go through, uh, whoops.
Okay.
Uh, you know, wou,d,
although plough, need.
Bread  instead of heard.
So, lots of examples of the
inconsistency of English spelling.
And what I'm trying to show you is that
you can, uh, if I go to my vocabulary
section now and I choose to filter by,
uh, pronunciation, then I'm gonna see
all the words that I have saved for
pronunciation, so there only happened to
be four, and so I could use the vocabulary
section as a way of trying to focus in on
words that I have difficulty pronouncing.
So I hope this is, uh, helpful to you.
I hope even that the lesson uh, helps
you work on your English pronunciation.
If you have any suggestions on
similar types of, uh, lessons that,
uh, we could create in different
languages, um, please let me know.
Go and do the lesson if you are learning
English, if you're having trouble with
spelling and if you find this useful,
again, I just did this on a, on a whim.
Uh, let me know if this helps.
Uh, I've made a similar lesson in French,
as you know, so if this is useful, I
can go and create lessons in different
languages, which focus in on some of the
aspects that people have trouble with.
And please let me know if you have
any particular issue that you would
like me to focus in on in this way.
And I can sort of tie them to
my video and tie them to lessons
that we create or that I could ask
native speakers of other languages
to create and put in our library.
I always like to leave you with,
uh, some relevant videos that you
might find interesting related to the
topic that I've, uh, been discussing.
So I suggest you visit, uh, a
video that I did a while ago.
Uh, simple tips about, uh, English
learning, and another one about
common mistakes that people have in
English in particular, this issue of
interesting interested and similar,
uh, uh, situations where I often hear
uh, non-native speakers, uh, saying,
you know, I am interesting in music
when they mean I'm interested in music.
Okay, thanks for listening.
Bye for now.